there's no secret that I love America
that's why no one asked me to the Sadie
Hawkins dance in high school they knew I
already had a date but lately America
has been changing she's not the 1950s
beauty that I used to love back when I
was waiting to be born no to be honest
sometimes I don't even recognize my
country anymore
[Music]
my first fading memory is football
yesterday was the Super Bowl which was
ruined when this pop-locking mountain
range Justin Timberlake did his halftime
show this elitist kook shouldn't be
allowed to do his Michael Jackson
cosplay anywhere near a football field
after what he said to reporters last
week when they asked him if his son
might play football one day just look
he will never play football okay no to
say no my kid can't play football coz
I'm worried you might take a hit it's
indicative of sort of this softness that
we get to me it's just an eye roll it's
like here we go again another guy that
won't let his kid play football yeah
yeah are we going in Peter doesn't just
look like the guy who broke Molly
Ringwald's heart at the beginning of
every 80s movie we know he makes a great
point I hear things like 48% of
Americans would encourage a child who
wanted to play football to play a
different sport due to concerns about
concussions and I wonder where the hell
am I do I hit my head and I'm now
hallucinating an America where people
aren't excited to send their tots off to
battle on the gridiron who cares
if players risk turning their brains
into deconstructed lasagna they do it
for a good cause they get sneakers with
their names on them
but some fathers are just wusses who
don't understand a thing about football
week pennyways like Justin Timberlake
and Mike Ditka typical Midwestern
coastal elites this continues what's
next
kids playing basketball wrapped in
bubble wrap divers landing in the ball
pit from Dave & Buster's
people playing soccer it makes me sick
is this even my country anymore and it's
not just football now we may lose our
great American pastime
no not baseball bullying indigenous
peoples and we combined both of these
passions in the Cleveland Indians
however I've said it before America is
changing and I don't like it the
Cleveland Indians announced the removal
of their controversial chief wahoo logo
from caps and Jersey starting in 2019
many groups consider it racist and
offensive I think they finally caved
nineteen forty-seven is we've been
seeing chief wahoo as a logo he was part
of the movie major leagues yeah he was
chief wahoo was in major league and
everyone in that movie is still standing
proud but the snowflakes want to
completely disregard the team's legacy
sorry libs they're the Cleveland Indians
and they always have been
except when they were a minor league
team called the Cleveland Lakeshore's
and a year later when they were renamed
the Cleveland Bluebirds and then the
year after that they were the Cleveland
Broncos and the next year they were
named the Cleveland Knapp's and then
became the Cleveland Molly Maguires
which is very very very confusing but
then they became the Cleveland Indians
so how could we possibly change it this
is another case of lips frothing at the
mouth trying to take away our history
what's next
take it aware of Confederate statues and
our toddler cigars which are while we're
on the subject they're temporarily still
available in the shop position this is
not the America I know but we're not
done prepare to lose your appetite
because Colonel Sanders is now Colonel
Sanders Reba McEntire now rocking the
iconic white suit and string tie yes
that's her making her the first female
to take over the role mentor I'm gonna
leave them right right here yes no Pete
no do not keep your thoughts inside you
know that gives you a tummy ache
look I'm no sexist my doctor says I'm
half lady DNA but a woman just doesn't
have this stamina to be the colonel we
need someone strong and tough to guard
the secret spices and what's with the
pantsuit and the short quaffed hair it's
like stop a tree but go back to the
woods and release your emails
this can't be America it just can't just
just snap me out of it Chuck give me a
land I can recognize do guns still
outnumber people here they do good can
you still get a root canal a little
Walmart's absolutely perfect do more
people still live in prison than in
Wyoming
then Wyoming and South Dakota combined
oh I love it
whoo touch-and-go for a second but yeah
this is definitely still America
[Music]